bonsoir notre invité de ce soir est l'un
des chefs de la coalition qui semble
devoir gagner les prochaines élections
législatives il se retrouvera lui même à
l'assemblée nationale à la tête de
quelques dizaines de députés fidèles
mais ce n'est pas un homme comme les
autres il est celui qui a été dans ce
pays
président de la république il est celui
qui sait parce que il a vécu de
l'intérieur
et il sait comment ça marche à la tête
de l'état et il est le seul à le savoir
vraiment son expérience est donc
précieuse dans la période actuelle les
français vous le savez monsieur le
président s'interroge sur ce qui va se
passer concrètement après le 16 mars
entre le président socialiste qui l'ont
élu il y a cinq ans et la nouvelle
assemblée dans laquelle sauf surprise
vous et vos amis obtiendrait la majorité
alors qu'est-ce qui se passera après
mars est ce que ce sera bon pour les
français
bon pour l'avenir de la france pourrait
vous gouvernez comment avec qui pour
faire quoi
c'est de tout ça c'est à dire de l'enjeu
de ce scrutin du 16 mars qui apparaît un
petit peu comme une inconnue pour les
gens dont nous allons débattre ce soir
et qui est français qui vous pose la
première question asvp jean-louis de
seine
valéry giscard d'estaing bonsoir vous
avez ici svp monsieur le président
beaucoup de questions sur votre personne
sur votre volonté de jouer à nouveau un
rôle national dans la vie politique
française pour les uns qui approuvent
votre détermination cela se traduit par
cette formule d'un téléspectateur bonne
année et à bientôt monsieur le président
ou bien par cette affirmation je voterai
pour vous pour les autres cette même
détermination nuit à l'opposition de
questions n'est-il pas inconvenant de
vouloir à nouveau être président après
l'échec personnel que vous avez subie en
80 et quelles raisons peut avoir fait
changer les français d'idées et de
sentiments à votre sujet en cinq ans
qu'est ce que je dois faire je répondre
à ces questions il ya plusieurs
questions n'ont d'abord un mot si vous
voulez sur ce que vous avez dit
à propos de cette émission je voudrais
pas que ceux qui nous regardent ce soir
crois que pour moi les élections c'est
gagné d'avancé et il ya quelque chose
qui me paraît tout à fait dommageable
c'est de se comporter d'agir comme si
c'était gagné en réalité on va voir un
choix national dans deux mois un mois et
demi c'est le premier choix national
puis 1980 il est très important et ce
qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est de
dire ce qui peut éclairer ce choix
national les conséquences du choix on en
dira un mot mais ce n'est pas
l'essentiel
d'accord vous rappeler la question jean
louis le scène oui quelles raisons peut
avoir fait changer les français à votre
égard donc monsieur président les
français d'idées de sentiments à votre
sujet en cinq années
alors les français ils ont changé deux
fois parce que avant 1980 vont un peu le
dernier sondage de ce avant 1980 il
croyait que je sois nouveau président
dans le public et on leur posait la
question c'est la sofres qu'on aura
alain duhamel tout à l'heure et j'avais
retrouvé ce sondage et quelques jours on
leur disait ce que vous trouvez que
monsieur giscard d'estaing est
sympathique et 70% répondait oui puis
ont changé après et ils ont changé c'est
naturel puisque quand on a un échec le
pignon change et ensuite ils ont eu
l'extraordinaire matraquage de
propagande des premières années 80 92 on
leur disait que tout ce qu'il aurait
peut-être arriver de mal cet c'est à
cause de moi
alors il est naturel qu'à ce moment là
leur opinion et changer mais dans les
questions vous posez je n'ai pas du tout
l'heure actuelle je pas venu ici pour
poser ma candidature à la présidence de
la république
je suis venu ici parce que nos
compatriotes ont un choix à faire que
j'ai des choses à dire que c'est chose
que j'ai à dire je trouve qu'on ne le
dit pas assez aux françaises et aux
français ce soir je vais essayer de les
dire vous allez dire et vous avez
surtout le dire directement c'est à dire
que vous pourrez pas dire que ça
s'entende un terme et décontractée ou ou
déformés bon alors je rappelle que les
téléspectateurs tout de même vont
intervenir de façon dans cette émission
la première phase on sait ce que vous
venez de voir ces les questions posées
par l'intermédiaire des s&p la seconde
c'est pour donner leur avis non plus
pour poser les questions et ça ça se
passe par l'intermédiaire du thé les
sondages sofres je rappelle que ce tte
les sondages est organisée auprès d'un
échantillon de 250 personnes qui est
qu'ils sont des gens qui sont installés
dans leurs foyers qui sont
représentatifs n'ont pas
l'auditoire qui nous écoutent ce soir
politiquement parlant mais de l'ensemble
de la france avec sa diversité politique
et socio professionnelles nous avons
sollicité un premier avis de cet
échantillon sofres sur les thèmes qui le
souhaiteraient pouvoir aborder ce soir
alors voilà l'ordre des priorités dans
les thèmes
est-ce qu'on peut les voir voilà alors
donc vous voyez bien largement en tête
les moyens que vous préconisez pour
réduire le chômage 65% puis ensuite on
souhaite vous voir parler de la
situation économique de la cohabitation
avec monsieur mitterrand et je vois
alors vais en dernière position
votre avenir personnel avec seulement 8%
la place de la france dans le monde 16 %
et et votre grand thème l'union entre
l'udf et le rpr seulement si je lis bien
16%
voila voila c'est voler une indication
pour les qui va peut aider les trois
journalistes qui vont maintenant vous
interrogez monsieur le président dans
l'ordre alain duhamel serge july
directeur de libération et albert du roy
alors j'appelle tout de suite alain
duhamel pour 15 minutes
je note simplement que le sondage le thé
les sondages que le nom de voir de la
sofres confirme parfaitement celui celui
quand tu es mieux et l'événement du
jeudi ont réalisé et que vous avez
commenté tout à l'heure une chose dans
le journal de 20h aux très bien notre
sondage c'est que il ya plus de
questions sur l'avenir personnel tant
mieux je ne faisais pas du tout en
parler par contre je regrette un petit
peu qu'on ait mis si loin dans le
sondage la place de la france dans le
monde
parce qu'à mon avis une question
importante est une question qui est des
conséquences sur les autres nous verrons
tout à l'heure oui mais vous avez vous
avez sur ce point plus d'une heure pour
faire changer les français d'avis alors
à l'année un quart d'heure à partir de
maintenant voilà monsieur giscard
d'estaing
si comme c'est arrivé un de vos anciens
premiers ministres il ya quelques jours
au cours d'une émission de télévision
une jeune chômeuse était intervenu pour
dire j'en ai assez je craque je m'en
vais ce langage ce n'est pas le mien je
ne comprends rien vous ne comprenez rien
mais
problème est de toute façon je n'attends
rien des hommes politiques est ce que
vous lui aurez y est dit d'abord
attendons
non parce qu'elle était invitée à la
mention en question j'aurais jeudi
avance que leur ai pensé
sa mort est confirmée dans quelque chose
que je pense que je le vois sur le
terrain c'est qu'il y a une énorme
distance entre les hommes politiques et
la jeunesse énorme distance plus
qu'avant je pense plus qu'avant oui il y
en avait déjà beaucoup il faut dire mais
je pense encore plus qu'avant et la
raison c'est que la jeunesse actuelle
c'est la jeunesse la crise et donc
chômage comme le dire cette jeune fille
et que d'hommes politiques sont
installés dans le confort du pouvoir
soit qu'ils étaient au pouvoir ce qui
est notre cas ils en sont partis je vois
que d'arriver au pouvoir isis on est
alors entre des gens qui vivent la crise
et des gens qui sont dans le confort du
pouvoir il ya très peu de communication
et je crois que à cette jeune fille il
fallait faire deux jours de battue
fallait avoir un certain humour dans une
situation pareille
et puis ensuite je crois qu'il fallait
lui parler du chômage et j'espère que
nous allons le faire tout à l'heure mais
on va le faire
je voulais d'abord avant d'y arriver
justement vous demandez vous êtes
solidaires de la plateforme que viennent
d'adopter le rpr et l'udf bien entendu
et vous vous considérez comme libérale
oui tout à fait bien alors si
l'opposition udf et rpr l'emportent elle
gouvernera dans des conditions
particulières par rapport aux habitudes
parce qu'elle sera que c'est une
échéance courte une échéance de deux ans
normalement on a un horizon un peu plus
lointain que ça est-ce que vous pensez
que pendant ces deux années
si par hypothèse gagne et naturellement
est-ce que vous pensez que pendant ces
deux années
vous pouvez faire en matière de chômage
aussi bien que ce café par exemple le
parti socialiste au pouvoir
la dernière année en 1985 autrement dit
la stabilisation
je pense qu'on peut faire un peu mieux
comment alors d'abord vous dites de gens
c'est vraiment faim les députés vont
être élus pour cinq ans il faut pas
toujours coupé la vie politique de la
france une législature c'est cinq ans
ensuite il vous était arrivé d'essayer
de faire démarrer une voiture dont les
freins non le frein à main et crs marche
pas vous n'arrivez pas si vous desserrer
le frein à main tout à coup vous dites
c'est quelque chose qui change ça va
mieux ça démarre et je crois qu'ils
accusent une chose qu'on peut faire deux
ans est de desserrer le frein à main
à l'heure actuelle l'économie française
à tous ces freins serrés elle est
contrôlée on en parlera tout à l'heure
rigidifier bureaucratisé on peut
desserrer phr et je crois que si on
dessert les freins de toute façon les
passagers se sentiront plus confortable
alors l'autre chose que je voulais dire
c'est que ce qu'on peut faire faut pas
tromper les gens
je vous rappelle la célèbre phrase qui a
trompé les français le 8 mai 81 de la
part de l'actuel président de la
république je dis aux jeunes jusqu'à
trois millions de jeunes qui n'ont pas
suivi cette campagne le 8 mai 81 g jour
cette phrase avec moi parce que je
trouve qu'il faut l'avoir en tête sur
l'emploi devant la télévision
françois mitterrand a dit je serai en
mesure de recruter un million de jeunes
dans l'année qui vient pour les
promesses qu'on faisait au français
alors nous ne ferons pas ses promesses
mais une seule chose ce qu'on peut
modifier assez vite en france c'est
l'augmentation du nombre des gens au
travail parce qu'actuellement dans les
pays voisins allemagne angleterre italie
le nombre des gens au travail augmente
et en france il diminue et je crois que
dans les deux ans à venir nous pouvons
recommencer à augmenter le nombre des
français au travail en ce qui concerne
ce soit des promesses soient des espoirs
exprimés ce que vous croyez que ce août
c'était un précédent ça n'est pas arrivé
à des personnalités aussi éminentes que
vous même au premier ministre de
l'époque de dire ah bah c'est vrai ça va
vraiment mieux
ou c'est vrai pour cette année vous
pouvez être tranquille ça va s'arranger
donc je prends matière au chômage ou à
la fois soul et les dirigeants et doit
faire deux choses c'est difficile c'est
un petit peu contradictoires d'une part
ils doivent dire ce qui est
et puis d'autres fins ils doivent donner
un peu d'espoir alors quand on donne de
l'espoir quelquefois l'espoir est
confirmée quelques fois l'espoir est
déçu bien une différence entre donner de
l'espoir à dire on va essayer et faire
des promesses qu'on ne peut pas tenir
et quand on dit je ferai ce si ça c'est
une promesse alors on la tient on la
tient pas alors parmi les freins à
desserrer comme vous dites il y en a
dont on parle souvent et et qui est la
libération des prix
la plateforme udf rpr prévoit cette
libération des prix et la prévoit même
vite
est ce que vous ne craignez pas comme
certains dirigeants politiques que si on
libère les prix tout de suite il
commence par y avoir immédiatement soit
une relance de l'inflation soit en tout
cas une surchauffe de l'indicent donc
peut-être un petit découragement chez
les gens alors non seulement pourra pas
le faire très vite faudra le faire tout
de suite passé cette histoire du
libéralisme en france est toujours la
même chose ça me fait penser aux gens
qui veulent se baigner
alors ils vont bord et piscine puis
tremper leurs pieds dans l'eau et elle
est froide il ce recul non quand on fait
quelque chose on le fait et si on doit
entrer dans l'économie libérale il
faudra prendre tout de suite les
décisions qu'ils montreront c'est une
économie libérale
j'ai reçu ce matin une lettre d'une
boulangère qui étaient affolés et les
affolé parce qu'elle vend son teint qui
est une demie baguette parisienne elle
levant 3 francs 80 et il paraît qu'elle
doit le vendre 3 francs 75 elle ne
savait pas parce qu'elle a mal fait la
division par 2 et moyennant quoi on la
convoque à la direction départementale
les prix ont la menace nous poursuites
est-ce qu'on va continuer à vivre dans
ce régime donc il faut faire comme les
autres comme l'allemagne les états-unis
tout le monde c'est-à-dire avoir la
liberté complète des prix alors vous me
dites les primes ont augmenté non je
vous pose la question est ce que les
prix vont augmenter alors je vous dire
si les prix doivent augmenter c'est au
gouvernement trompent les français comme
il dit à l'heure actuelle il n'y a plus
d'inflation
s'il n'y a plus d'inflation est qu'à
supprimer le contrôle des prix et si il
dit si on supprime le contrôler les prix
les prix vont augmenter c'est qu'il y a
donc encore de l'inflation moi je vous
dois on évalue il peut y avoir une autre
explication aussi à sa trace moment là
c'est qu' un certain nombre de gens qui
jusqu'à présent n'ont pas eu la liberté
de fixer leurs prix qui au moment où la
leur donne ce disque dépêchons nous de
les augmenter parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
qui se passera dans trois mois ou dans
six mois non je crois que si vous
connaissez les studios situation exacte
des entreprises en france est
actuellement une terrible concurrence
si vous croyez qu'à l'heure actuelle la
distribution dans le commerce dans les
petites entreprises ont peu augmenté
librement ses prix vous trompez tout à
fait donc là dessus vous êtes confiant
libérera les prix tout de suite et je
pense que
les conséquences seront très limités
parce que nous sommes dans une période
de baisse des prix mondiaux c'est ça qui
fait d'ailleurs nous avons dû prix
modérés en franche baisse des matières
premières baisse du pétrole
alors il y a toujours dans la plateforme
eu d'effet repérées sur des points
concrets qu'un petit peut frapper les
gens apparemment il ya une question qui
soulève déjà des polémiques c'est la
suppression de l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes et en même temps l'abaissement
de la tranche d'imposition supérieure de
l'impôt sur le revenu alors est-ce que
effectivement c'est pas un petit peu
provocateur d'annoncer à l'avance des
avantages pour les plus riches sans
prévoir quelque chose de plus pour les
plus pauvres un moment donné est ce que
par exemple serait pas été plus habile
moi je ne sais pas de dire l'impôt
seconde fortune il sera perçu mais au
lieu d'être confisquée par exemple il
sera obligatoirement investis cajou de
ce genre je crois qu'il faut être
courageux faut dire les choses quand
vous parlez à quelqu'un de l'impôt sur
le revenu il vous dit par exemple eh
bien moi c'est décourageant pour moi
parce que je un mois de mon travail je
le paie sous forme d'impôts alors un
mois de son travail qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire 8% et le taux de
l'impôt maximum sur le revenu à l'heure
actuelle il est de 65%
ce qui veut dire que ceux qui dansent
sont dans cette tranche y travaillent
neuf fois sur 12 pour le fisc quand on
travaille neuf mois sur douze pour le
fisc on ne travaille plus élevé de gens
le nombre de gens vous pouvez trouver
qui sont des gens très utile à la
société qui sont des inventeurs qui sont
des grands médecins etc sont des gens
qui ont développé récemment une
entreprise de technologie uhs i je
m'arrête et parfois ils vous dis-je
je vais ailleurs et tous les grands pays
pour leur relance il faut pas faire de
la démagogie en transe les français sont
plus intelligents que ceux là
heureusement savent que si on dit à
quelqu'un qu'il travaille neuf mois sur
douze sur douze pour le fisc il
travaillera plus que vont connaître les
hommes politiques c'est pas justement de
régler ce couple solidarité motivation
performances économiques
alors ça comme celle très grande
question c'est doit passer par ici c'est
une grande question puisque sur lequel
on peut répondre brièvement oui est ce
qu'on ne peut pas avoir un peu de
solidarité et en même temps motiver les
gens est ce que c'est parce à l'avenir
de nos sociétés bien sûr mais écoutez je
suis le seul président de la république
qui a été élu sur incrédule
heures et je vous le rappelle parce que
comme c'était en 74 qu'on est en 86 si
elles ont 12 ans et comme il ya 12 ans
élu millions de français qui n'étaient
pas là mais déjà monsieur mitterrand
c'était télévision me disait fait le
combat des risques contre les pauvres et
j'ai explosé c'est à peu près pareil
c'est pas un truc de communication j'ai
explosé je lui ai dit monsieur
mitterrand vous n'avez pas le monopole
du coeur et ce soir là j'ai gagné cinq
cent mille voix d'après les études et
sondages
je les ai gardés j'étais donc j'ai été
élu sur un cri du coeur et je ne
laisserai pas recommandée recommencer
cette mauvaise comédie de la lutte des
riches contre les pauvres parce que la
vérité à l'heure actuelle c'est
d'accroître la richesse des français
et ça n'est pas d'assister passivement
comme on le fait à la naissance des
nouveaux pauvres et la politique que
nous proposons c'est une politique qui
augmentera les richesses des français de
toutes catégories et si on vient sur ce
sujet tout à l'heure vous montrerai que
nous sommes plus occupé des français
défavorisés qu'on a fait depuis quatre
ans car qu'est-ce qui s'est occupée des
handicapés qu'est-ce qui s'est occupé de
l'assurance des veuves et en ce qui
concerne les petites catégories
par exemple les retraités la sécurité
sociale nous avons plus augmenté leur
retraite pendant la crise qu'on a fait
maintenance etc
vous dites vous dites qu'il faut parler
vrai et socialistes ont fait ça nombre
de choses dans le domaine social comme
lesquels peut pas dire que l'on peut pas
dire qu'il se soit comportée que des
réactionnaires non pas les actionnaires
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait on a
ralenti l'effort de travail des français
il augmenter le smic au début par
exemple si vous demandez loeb n'en est
qu'au début il fallait augmenter
ils ont donné pour tout le monde une
semaine de vacances en plus de vacances
en plus je dis bien qui existait déjà
pour certains qu'ils ont donnée pour
tout le monde
ou bien ils ont
abaissé l'âge de la retraite c'est
l'effort de travail des français bon
est-ce qu'il fallait diminuer l'effort
de travail des français pendant la crise
grande question est ce que vous mais est
ce qu'ils ont non mais je réponds parce
qu'il faut dire ça aux français moi je
tends lunaire les autres parlent 24
heures sur 24 au beau ici tout le monde
ne parle dans les mêmes conditions
on est un symbole mais plus raser la rue
ici ici parce que déjà très bien mais si
vous prenez les petites catégories
il faut être concret prenez par exemple
les familles de trois enfants et plus
j'en gardais ça aujourd'hui
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat de
leurs prestations sociales depuis 81 06
faune et les retraites de la sécurité
sociale c'est pas des grosses retraites
c'est parler un beau choix fortune ça
pendant le septennat augmenté de 20% en
pouvoir d'achat depuis 1981 elles ont
baissé
voilà les situations concrètes alors il
faut pas laisser croire qui a d'un côté
des gens qui ont une générosité qui
s'occupe des catégories défavorisées
et puis d'euros de ça leur est égal et
se contente ce que nous voulons c'est
remettre l'économie française en marche
mais l'étude par exemple s'adressant aux
jeunes chômeurs les tuques au début
quand on les a créés l'opposition harry
caine et en disant c'est un truc de plus
puis maintenant finalement vous les
remettez pas en cause votre trouvez que
c'est plutôt bien de manger jamais
ricaner sur les j'ai vu que j'ai pas dis
vous spécialement j'ai dit dans
l'opposition bon déjà mais ricaner sur
l'étude peut-elle vous rappeler parce
que j'ai vérifié sa chanonat puy de dôme
hier vous avez ce que gagne un tuk egan
1250 francs par mois
alors c'est très bien de dire qu'on va
pas toucher au smic alors que le smic c4
1400 francs mais l'étude jeunes gens et
jeunes femmes y gagnent 1250 francs par
mois à l'heure actuelle et les
collectivités locales peuvent ajouter
500 francs et pas plus donc ceux qui ont
le plus et 1750 francs et ceux qui ont
le moins c'est 1250 francs et c'est
mieux que d'être chez soi ne rien faire
et d'attendre un emploi qui arrive qui
n'arrive pas c'est mieux mais ce n'est
pas le smic et le smi vous êtes partisan
d'y toucher ou pas alors j'ai appris que
d'assouplir le système ou pas de porter
quelque chose qui va vous intéresser
je portais beaucoup de papier enfin
quelques-uns qui que je voulais vous
montrer le schmidt
enfin on fait peur aux français et aux
français on leur dit l'udf leur prc des
réactionnaires n'est ce pas et ventes
chez au smic le smic il date de quand
c'est une loi qui a été votée en 1969
cette terre le président pompidou qui
est un président de la république
j'étais ministre de l'économie et des
finances responsable de l'économie et
des finances nous déposons le projet de
loi créant le chemise un débat long
débat et ont fait voter voilà le papier
de l'assemblée nationale analyse du
scrutin
du mercredi 10 décembre 69 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi portant
création du smic ont voté pour lui d air
actuel rpr les républicains indépendants
le ski était le cds sont rendus l'udf
ont voté contre les socialistes et
apparentés et les communistes et il
avait à cette époque des donnes inscrits
dans l'âme et 13 sur ces deux inscrit 11
ans voté pour et deux ont voté contre
monsieur françois mitterrand et michel
rocard voilà le vote sur le smi le 10
décembre 69 alors je veux simplement
dire par là que il faut parler
sérieusement de ces sujets et si la loi
que nous avons voté était une bonne loi
il faut dire vous ai fait une très bonne
loi est ce que maintenant sept partisans
de l'assouplir je suis d'un modifiée
sous dire nous allons parler gisement a
bien sûr mais nous allons parler
j'espère de l'emploi des jeunes
parce que tu un grand problème est tout
à l'heure je crois sur les sondages on
le mettait en tête de toutes les
préoccupations et il ne faut pas partir
d'une attitude disant qu'est-ce qu'on
touche que ce cauchemar faut partir
d'une attitude qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour augmenter l'emploi et
notamment l'emploi des jeunes en france
quand je vous dis tout de suite il
s'agit pas de revenir sur les garanties
que les gens en taxi en matière de smic
mais il s'agit de savoir comment avoir
une politique générale des rémunérations
en france dans l'avenir qui fasse que il
y est une création d'emplois plus active
qu'il y ait une meilleure adaptation de
la rémunération au travail et qu'en
particulier les entreprises soient
incitées à recruter des jeunes
donc ceux qui ont fait voter le smic
n'ont pas de leçons à recevoir de ceux
qui ont voté contre parce qu'il ya un
point sur lequel on discute aussi
beaucoup qui est de savoir si justement
sans vouloir être démagogique
on peut à la fois dès le départ alléger
la fiscalité sur les entreprises et
alléger la fiscalité sur les français
sur les citoyens
est ce qu'on peut faire les deux à la
fois par exemple dès la première année
la première année d'abord sur une demi
année
oui oui bien sûr espoir et puis où vous
placez toujours dans cette hypothèse de
l'élection et je vous rappelle telepac
qu'ils l'élection non mais ça s'est
arrêté j'ai dit que c'était l'hypothèse
de départ sur wii il est intéressant de
vous interroger sur ce que vous comptiez
faire que sur ce compte faire les
socialistes bien sûr c'est qu'on
adhérence dans ce cas là le rappeler
parce que je n'aime pas du tout cette
idée qui est souvent le fil au public
cette fois que des hommes politiques ils
croient qu'ils sont achetés les marques
et bien perdu vous voilà vous n'aimeriez
pas beaucoup qu'on vous dise le
contraire non plus une rom il faut être
simple et d'élections non sur la
fiscalité vous avez deux deux périodes
allez la fin de l'année 86 nouvelle
année 87 donc sur la fin de l'année 86
faudra d'abord remettre les comptes en
ordre faudra savoir quelle est la vérité
des comptes exacts et on ne pourra faire
que des allégements très limité en 86
pour 87 ça dépendra de ce qu'on pourra
faire comme et et demi si on peut faire
des économies importantes et je le crois
sont posé question parlerait si on peut
faire des économies importantes
une partie des économies à la réduction
du déficit
car il faut réduire notre déficit et une
partie ira la réduction des charges
première réduction des charges
je vous dirais qu'à mon avis il faudra
donner la priorité à la réduction des
charges qui bénéficie à l'emploi
faudra voir quelles sont les charges qui
pénalise l'emploi et c'est celle là
qu'il faudra commencer par réduit alors
comme je vois que virieu envie de me
dire que le temps est passé
deux petites questions politiques pour
terminer en ce qui me concerne deux
petites questions politiques la première
est ce que vous considérez toujours
comme vous l'aviez dit une fois la
télévision que raymond barre et le
meilleur économiste de france procédure
que raymond barre est un très bonne
économie choc qualifiés pour faire un
jury d'agrégation vous l'aviez qualifier
l'ol olivier camp
nommé puisque j'avais choisi en effet
parmi des douanes politiques jettent un
très bonne et que vous lui retirez pas
le titre non bon et dernière question
très brève avec une réponse très brève
dernière question est ce que vous croyez
sincèrement alors ça c'est pas de la
politique anecdotique
est ce que vous croyez sincèrement que
des gens comme jacques chirac que vous
même des gens qui appartiennent à des
sensibilités différentes même si ce sont
en gros les mêmes options et qui se sont
si mal entendu un moment au pouvoir
pourrait demain bien s'entendre ensemble
de nouveaux pouvoirs et si oui comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer je lui
explique d'abord je le crois et je
l'expliquent parce que bon il ya les
questions de personnes et les rivalités
il ya les ambitions là le sondeur plus
vive à certains moments de la vie qu'à
d'autres
et puis il ya la solidarité dans dans
les grandes épreuves les grandes actions
regardez par exemple je crois que fabius
est allé faire une réunion commune avec
avec mauroy à lille
allez je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient entre
eux une affection sans limite
mais au moment du combat mais ils
resserrent les rangs et il sait les
réunions ensemble et moi je vous dirais
que avec clé entre les gaullistes et les
libéraux ils ont quelque chose de très
fort en commun c'est eux qui ont fait la
cinquième république
tous les gouvernements d'un cinquième
but depuis le début c'étaient les
gaullistes et les libéraux ça c'était
vrai avant 81 ans et sa du oui mais
justement dans les grandes circonstances
d'un grandes circonstances on retrouve
cet instinct naturel et nous avons
fondamentalement les mêmes de vue
objectif parfait et nous allons
retourner
nous allons retourner svp jean lui la
scène d'autres questions oui beaucoup de
questions monsieur le président sur le
pouvoir d'achat sur l'évolution du
pouvoir d'achat est également sur
l'audiovisuel alors sur le pouvoir
d'achat depuis 90 et téléspectateurs et
malgré les promesses notre pouvoir
d'achat baisser considérablement
qu'est-il prévu concrètement dans votre
programme pour y remédier pouvez-vous
vraiment faire mieux que les socialistes
vous dirait j'ai pas beaucoup revenir au
passé mais malheureusement il faut quand
même comparé ce qu'on a fait les uns les
autres
alors au point de vue du pouvoir d'achat
il ya quelques semaines j'ai lu dans un
journal américain article en disant
pouvoir d'achat baisse en france
en réalité c'est ce n'est pas pire
qu'avant parce que le pouvoir d'achat
avait baissé sous giscard
alors j'ai écrit à ce journal j'ai
repris les calculs on voyait ça et ils
ont publié un rectificatif en dix ans
pendant le septennat de monsieur giscard
d'estaing le pouvoir d'achat augmenté en
france de 21%
c'est giscard qui a raison donc malgré
la crise on allait augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat est depuis 81 vous avez raison
il augmenter un petit peu mais très peu
ont été la moitié à peu près du rythme
d'avant les gens le savent ils le vivent
alors qu'elle sortait sur l'avenir oui
c'est ça alors deux manches personne ne
conteste que voulait dire
la question porte sur l'avenir est ce
qu'on pourrait faire mieux que les
socialistes en matière de voyages
je pense que oui pour des raisons qui
tiennent à la politique pour des gens
qui tiennent à l'environnement
international
d'abord concernant la politique c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
peut déférer les fronts le jour en
déférera les freins et on peut le faire
tout de suite pour les entreprises
petites et moyennes vous verrez
l'économie française repartir si elle
repart elle produira du pouvoir d'achat
est ensuite l'économie internationale
qui a subi une crise épouvantable en 80
81 et que les français ne connaissent
pas on leur avait raconté qu'il avait
pas de crise quand vous regardez
maintenant cette période c'était une
crise épouvantable c'est crise elle est
finie et en allemagne et aux etats unis
même en grande bretagne l heure actuelle
l'économie redémarre et progresse dans
des conditions raisonnables donc
normalement si la france est une bonne
politique
on serait dans la même situation et on
aurait une reprise de notre activité
ça ne peut pas se faire du jour au
lendemain c'est pas le 17 mars qu'on
assistera à la reprise de la progression
du pouvoir d'achat en france mais je
considère que dans une période de deux
ans sur 86 87
on pourrait amorcer la reprise de la
progression du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour
pour l'avenir des français est ce que
c'est la baisse du prix du pétrole ou
est ce que c'est le résultat des
élections de mars
bon d'abord la baisse du prix du pétrole
on ne sait pas le temps qu'elle va nous
aider avec l'environnement international
je crois que c'est très important pour
la france qui ne produit pas de pétrole
de voir le prix du pétrole effacent
c'est le deuxième choc pétrolier pas
nous avons eu un premier choc pétrolier
qui était dans une certaine mesure
j'allais dire justifier le pétrole était
sans doute dans le monde trop bon marché
dans les années soixante dix alors on
l'a porté à 16 dollars le baril
brutalement grande se couchent nos
enfants c'est un prix qui correspondait
un prix de production du pétrole
et puis l'heure les événements d'hier en
t2 purement politique la chute du chah
d'iran et le pétrole a encore plus que
doublé puisqu'il est passé de 16 $
blaisbois 2,38 dollars ou 42 dollar un
certain moment et ça c'était
complètement artificielle et ça nous a
ruinés en 81 81 ans 81 81 or maintenant
le 2 le plus de pétrole revient dans les
zones de 20 $ 18 dollars c'est à dire
qu'au fond le deuxième choc pétrolier a
disparu et un gros handicap qui pesait
sur l'économie française disparaît alors
je souhaite que cette situation
naturellement soient ses tables en fête
le choc pétrolier s'est poursuivi quand
même sous les socialistes oui bien sûr
je sais a constitué en rentrant sur 20
du dollar etc
on peut pas dire qu'ils aient eu une
période complètement calme par
opposition à celle que vous avez eu
assez bon serge july maintenant pour le
deuxième quart d'heure il retournera
ensuite à svp
bonsoir toi eux
on va essayer d'être tout aussi concrète
pendant le premier quart d'heure pas
prendre les premières 25 minutes donc je
vais vous demander qu'est-ce qui sait
pas ce qu'est ce qui va se passer très
concrètement le 17 mars
alors ma première question c'est la
suivante prenons une hypothèse
vraisemblable
le président de la république vous
téléphonent à 10 heures le matin le 17
mai c'est vraisemblable ça fait
l'invraisemblable pourquoi pourquoi le
quitté les feux le 17 aux manèges sans
nouvelles
il saura vous joindre mon ami y aura pas
de problème beaucoup les booking
téléphone du 7 au 10 mai c'est une
hypothèse vraisemblable jeudi un jeune
euh non elle n'est pas vraisemblable
il appelle quelqu'un toute façon il va
bien désigner un premier ministre
donc il appelle quelqu'un notamment il
peut vous appeler donc quelques faits
cette personne et ce cas une procédure
qui est prévue entre les membres de
l'opposition ont fait entre les partis
de l'opposition
est ce qu'il ya une part presque dire
que prévu donc au cas où c'est vous
monsieur chirac on que madame veil ou
quelqu'un d'autre
qu'est ce qui se passe est ce que cette
personne téléphone immédiatement à
monsieur giscard d'estaing ou à monsieur
chirac ou à monsieur bart est ce qu'il
ya une réunion des instances politiques
que se passe-t-il bon alors j'espère
qu'on me revient au concret station très
concrète ça vous savez exactement
comment ça va se passer de l'avis des
français alors d'abord moi je vous dire
que tu te 17 au matin où je serai en
auvergne le 18 ou je serai en auvergne
19 et c'est bon vous allez passer en
auvergne tout le temps m jeu est bien où
nous parlons de 27 à l'heure mais le
pourquoi
c'est d'abord que la première chose qui
va se passer ça va être les élections
aux conseils régionaux première réunion
a les élections du 16 mars et les
conseils régionaux
ça se passe sur place ensuite le
parlement il se réunit le deuxième
rideau avant alors dans l'intervalle le
président de la république aura nommé un
premier ministre
à la porte là d'une chose simple c'est
que il le nomme il ya des gens qui
disent il faut que l'opposition se
réunit ce nom c'est son pouvoir et même
dans des pays où présence d'un public
n'a pas d'énormes pouvoirs canton de nos
voisins italiens
voyez quand il ya des crises ce prénom
olympiques ou normes le premier don qui
le nomme un mystérieux partir de là le
problème nous tardons voilà à tirer la
queue la question
seulement il le nomme dans des limites
très précises parce que 15 jours plus
tard ou dix jours plus tard ce premier
ministre il ira devant l'assemblée mais
imaginons qu'ils vous nomme ou qui nomme
monsieur chirac ou madame lie donc se
prend d hypothèse vraisemblable
je veux dire il peut tout à fait la
nommer donc votre choix vous le faites
comment vous le faites en votre âme et
conscience où vous allez en référer à
une instance particulière sk une
procédure qui était prévu entre le rpr
et l'udf pour traiter cette question
quand il ya le premier coup de téléphone
non et une honorable il y en aura pas
donc c'est en votre âme et conscience
que vous décidez d'aller voir le
président de la république et de dire
oui j'accepte attelle et telles
conditions
non mais c'est un contrat avant tout à
fait précis il n'y a pas de procédure
c'est à dire qu'il ne faut pas et que ce
serait tout à fait contraire à l'esprit
des institutions de la vème république
de dire on se réunit un comité choisit
le premier ministre mais c'était pas
question très important par contre le
présent dans le public saura que s'il se
trompe dans son choix
ici seul le premier nice n'a pas la
confiance de la majorité udf rpr son
gouvernement ne pourra pas démarrer très
bien mais il idem du point de vue la
procédure c'est le premier ministre qui
a été désigné par le président la
république qui va choisir nommer un
président un public qui va choisir ses
ministres se souvenir a pas de
négociation avec des états majors de
partis des deux partis qui forment la
coalition vous reste il y aura des
négociations non urba de négociation
simplement c'est la vie d'une coalition
dans une coalition mais les gens se
rencontrent le premier ministre
cherchera j'imagine constituer un bon
gouvernement est donc un gouvernement
qui représente la majorité et leur a
certainement le désirent à la fois drian
des gens très compétents ce qu'il le
faudra et en même temps d'avoir un bon
équilibre politique de son gouvernement
mais c'est ce qu'ont fait chaque fois
qu'on fait un gouvernement très bien
il ya quand ce que dernière question sur
ce point quand le premier ministre qui a
été nommé va voir le président a publié
ce qui lui présente des exigences
programmatique particulière son problème
c'est son nom en son âme et conscience
on est ce qu'il est pour lui demande
hulu exige du un système de relations un
partage du pouvoir entre lui et le
président à un public sur des questions
clés des mauges là aussi c'est en son
âme et conscience
non mais par exemple si c'était vous
voulez vous feriez ou non non enfin
imaginons c'est un calcul hypothèse on
indique tony poncet pas une provocation
s'il vous plaît ce type tout le préfet
mais le nom c'est beaucoup plus simple
est ce que le dire elle sera ma
conclusion tout à l'heure c'est
simplement là il faut respecter la règle
la france a une constitution et ce
constitution elle est tout à fait clair
enfin on prétend que les temps brouillé
c'est pas vrai lisez là elle est tout à
fait clair et simplement
chacun devra respecter la constitution
et celui qui ne la respecteraient pas
aussi haut placé son inutile et prend le
risque est donc la règle c'est la
constitution d'ailleurs je n'indique une
jauge et apporter la construction de
nombreux bains avec padres toujours
utile déforme pas à l'étang qui par les
temps qui courent on sait maintenant il
vous la connaissez par coeur
oui mais c'était normal j'étais chargé
de veiller à son application est la
mieux la connaissez vous dis simplement
il ya un titre c'est très important
assure tout à fait simple temps de
comprendre le titre 5 de la constitution
qui s'appelle les rapports du
gouvernement et du parlement
autrement dit les rapports du
gouvernement et du parlement c'est un
dispositif de la constitution dans
lequel le président de la république
n'intervient pas on va ça sera la règle
les rapports du gouvernement et du
parlement oui mais vous venez de dire
une phrase qui me semble très importante
par rapport au pouvoir du président de
la république
si vous êtes le gardien de la
constitution avait été le dernier à la
constitution oui donc vous êtes avec le
conseil constitionnel vous avez été le
président la république françois
mitterrand va être l'un des interprètes
de cette constitution
quand on gouverne on gouverne par
décrets puisque par loi donc vous vous à
le premier ministre amène des décrets
les soumet au président président dit ça
ne correspond pas la constitution
qu'est-ce qui se passe non il faut
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
c'est tout le président république n'a
pas de pouvoir d'appréciation
constitutionnel et qu'il peut il veille
au respect
si donc un texte paraît poser une
question constitutionnelle ont saisi le
conseil constitutionnel soit parce que
j'avais fait toute une histoire aussi
ancienne mais enfin on peut les raconter
il ya vu quand j'avais proposé qu'on
élise le parlement européen au suffrage
universel parce que vous souvenez on
avait dit mais c'est un scandale c'est
contraire à la constitution les français
peuvent pas élire des députés européens
eh bien j'avais saisi le conseil
constitutionnel c'était à l'automne de
1978 et conseil constitutionnel a
délibéré très longuement et donne un
avis favorable
non mais une chose qu'il faut que les
français sachent parce qu'aussi c'est
qu'il n'y a pas en france de pouvoir de
veto des lois au président de la
république et beaucoup de gens disent il
peut refuser de signer non les lois non
non il n'y a pas de droit de veto en
france aux états unis un droit de veto
en france n'ont jamais un président de
la république n'a pu s'opposer à une loi
tout ce qui fait c'est qu'il a promu il
a pu ainsi l'élève et la même année la
décision il ya des l'impératif de tout
ce qui peut faire il peut à la rigueur
vous savez que c'était fait une fois
d'ailleurs demandé une seconde lecture
est sain et c'est tout et une fois que
la seconde lecture lieu la loi doit être
première personne ne peut suivre pouvoir
ne nomme le premier ministre
pouvoir dissolution et donc on renvoie
au conseil constitutionnel est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres pouvoirs du voeu du
président de la république dans le type
de situation nous examinons ce soir oui
mais enfin je crois que c'est un petit 1
pendant ne rien pouvoir si vous voulez
qui est la nomination de certains hauts
personnages
cette nomination elle est faite en
conseil des ministres est donc présent
dans le public est là et il préside le
conseil des ministres dans ces
nominations il est présent et la navy
naturellement il le donne
qu'est ce qui se passe s'il est en
conflit avec le gouvernement
en fait ça ne s'est jamais produit alors
ça c'est difficile à imaginer
la seule fois où ça s'est produit dans
l'histoire de france c'est l'histoire de
mac mahon carcan mcmahon est le
président de la république il ya eu un
changement de
majorité et on lui a proposé de révoquer
je crois 50 généraux il a refusé les
dunes on refuse de signer et trois mois
après il est parti donc a pas de
précédent et je crois que sur ce sujet
il faut se dire que sur les quelques
emplois nominations importantes
il doit pas y avoir de conflit et vaut
donc qu'il y ait une réflexion attentive
de l'intérêt national de procéder at
elle ou quelqu'un est ce qu'il ya pas d
pouvoir de fait j'en finis sur la
question des pouvoirs du président
est-ce qu'il ya pas d pouvoir de fait
par exemple en politique étrangère
est ce que le fait que monsieur
gorbatchev par exemple va inviter le
président la république et ensuite
monsieur reagan vallat vite et ensuite
sans madame thatcher et puis la vie tu
pas le premier ni ce qu'est ce qui se
passe
non c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est
passé ça se passait à vous qui l'incité
des invitations aux fruits mais dans les
invitations soul et je veux pas
caricaturer les choses mais vous avez
des types d'événements tout à fait
différent vous avez des chefs d'état qui
vont se voir les uns chez les autres ça
n'a aucune conséquence pratique sur un
mondial et ses enfants vous avez au
contraire des chefs d'état qui vont se
voir pour négocier et à ce moment là il
faut qu'ils soient responsables du
gouvernement s'ils sont pas responsables
du gouvernement ils peuvent pas
l'engager et nos interlocuteurs
étrangers le savent très bien quand vous
allez voir quelqu'un il se dit est-ce
que vous avez le pouvoir de le faire si
vous le dites je veux faire ceci vaut
mieux pas le pouvoir de le faire
tout le monde le sait dont vous ne venez
pas de d'audience vis-à-vis de lui donc
il ya des sujets sur lesquels par
exemple la politique française est
actuellement je dirais bipartisane pas
d'antagonisme pour la plupart des sujets
européens
à l'heure actuelle puis son bi partisan
donc c'est le président de la république
et met un point de vue quel point de vue
soutenu par le gouvernement pour le pays
a pas de difficultés si ce sont des
sujets difficiles politique vis-à-vis de
la libye par exemple il est évident que
ce sont des sujets difficiles qui touche
le gouvernement les intérêts économiques
eux les responsabilités militaires et à
ce moment là on ne peut pas agir dans
l'ignorance du gouvernement j'en finis
sur ce point mais ça va être un problème
pour la france et en particulier pour sa
politique d' éviter que des puissances
étrangères
joutes du
un conflit éventuel entre le président
de la république et le premier ministre
sur les questions polies étrangères donc
en jouant plutôt l'un contre l'autre en
particulier dans les consciences
vinciane donc il faut qu'il y ait un
accord qui se détermine qui fait quoi au
niveau la politique étrangère du
président à un public est prévue une
pensée cet accord possible donc pas trop
mal passé difficile il faut pas faux pas
dorer la pilule mais je pense que c'est
possible c'est possible troisième
question si sur la majorité donc vous
savez qu'il ya eu plusieurs instituts
tout le monde est arrivé à peu près au
même résultat
une chiffre d'ailleurs utilisé à la fois
par le rp enfin je cite des sources donc
à la fois par le rpr et par matignon
dix ans que skis a pas un risque qu'il y
ait une majorité fictive
c'est à dire que comme monsieur bart
vient d'annoncer de manière tout à fait
redondantes
dans une interview à fait argument que
d'autres façons il voterait pas la
confiance au gouvernement
alors vous avez demandé vous à
l'ouverture de la session parlementaire
un vote de confiance tout le monde
évalue à peu près à 50 députés d'ariste
donc le nombre de députés qui ne
voterait pas la confiance est ce que ça
ne crée pas un problème pour une
majorité est ce que ça ne vous oblige
pas avoir en fait y compris avec des
varices près de 300 des plus de 3 un peu
plus de 300 députés justement donc en
majorité large un tout petit peu de
cette majorité d'abord quelque chose
qu'il faut dire on a un très mauvais
système électoral le système de la
proportionnelle est détestable et tous
ceux qui viennent de vivre un petit peu
la préparation des listes en province
sauf que c'est un système détestable
alors la première chose qu'il faudra
faire c'est de le changer pour que vous
avez changé d'opinion d'ailleurs sur
cette question vous aviez dit après
l'adoption la conventionnelle qui fait
le changer par référendum
hellal votre conférence de presse en
janvier
vous avez déclaré qu'il fallait changer
parfois parlementaires non c'est à dire
je préférais je pense que la loi
électorale doit échanger par référendum
seulement nous serons dans une situation
particulière jusqu'à le président de la
république et je pense qu'il faut
d'abord que le parlement
de toute façon je crois que d'abord le
parlement de toute façon devra voter le
changement
le gouvernement devra voir si les
intérêts alsol anisé par un référendum
en trait il faudra le voter tout de
suite qui le vôtre a uniquement l'udf et
le rpr
les petites listes votre encontre
naturellement parce que les petites
listes disparaissent si un scrutin
majoritaire dans les petites listes
votre encontre
le front national votre à contre les
socialistes qui ont créé la
proportionnelle votre encontre des
communistes qui sont pour la
proportionnelle votre encontre
donc je dis aux électeurs très important
s'ils veulent retrouver une situation
dans laquelle ils pourront à nouveau
choisir leurs députés
c'est seulement en votant pour les udf
pour leur père qu'ils ont une chance de
l'obtenir certain point je vous ai posé
une question sur le député bart est non
mais là sur ce
sur ce point c'est essentiel il faut le
dire il faut que tout le monde le
chargement de mettre son bulletin de
vote dans l'urne
si vous voulez revenir nous électorale
vous choisirez votre député
la seule chance c'est de voter pour les
députés udf rpr
alors l'autre question c'est vous dites
y aura des députés baril si elle bat un
risque d'avoir une majorité fictive ya
pas de majorité la france sera
ingouvernable
et si la france est ingouvernable elle
ne résoudra aucun de ces problèmes ni le
problème du chômage les problèmes du
redémarrage de son économie ni le
problème de l' allègement des charges et
des et des complications toutes les
petites entreprises
elle n'en résoudra aucun cas ce risque
est réel ce risque est réel monsieur
barils là il a dit tellement de fois
maintenant que on a six semaines du
scrutin il va pas changer la vie le 2
avril à l'époque passé deux choses il
peut se passer la porte les électeurs ne
votent pas n'en voit pas une majorité au
parlement
c'est possible dans ce cas là la france
est ingouvernable et cela fera son
malheur tiens vous ne passez pas par
exemple qu'un gouvernement minoritaire
socialiste est à 30 si les socialistes
ont 30 32 % 33 consciente non non je
demande à monsieur chirac a dit que
c'était possible soit entre 25 et 30
leur coûtait rien je vous pose une
question moi je vous réponds moi je vais
gouverner la torture qu'on m'aide il
n'arrivait le côté absurde
moi quand j'ai été battue j'ai été battu
j'avais 48% des voix
oui non et on veut dire dès maintenant
des gens qui ont envie 30% des voix vont
gouverner la france
ça tient pas debout je pars à gouverner
oui il était prend votre premier
ministre avec une minorité nous non pas
une minorité de députés
maintenant il faut toujours avoir une
majorité des députés parce que sinon le
gouvernement fr
il sera réalisé en au sein de la
majorité non si si c'est ça qui se passe
à l' on n'est pas là pour faire de
petites fictions marseille c'est dire
les choses si tracy creil site noyer
bientôt en plus un donc s'il n'y a pas
de majorité
la france est ingouvernable et ça fera
son malheur elle aura une dissolution
dans l'année qui vient
cette dissolution se fera encore à la
proportionnelle elle ne donnera toujours
pas de majorité et la france sera
retourné pour toujours à la ivème
république
voilà ce qui l'attend je vous préviens
là bon je vous voyais je vous dit ce que
j'ai sur le coeur pour impression
sociaux est cette fois bien par contre
alors l'autre histoire l'histoire des
députés de la majorité
la future majorité qui ne voteront pas
la confiance je dis qu 3par vous y
croyez pas donc on se trompe
il peut y avoir une personnalité qui
pour des raisons mais les orphelins les
autres votre écoute et 0,15 à me
rappeler une année risque non je dis
vous étiez vous avez de la chance à lyon
mais moi j'ai assisté à l'arrivée du
général de gaulle
j'étais tout jeune député j'avais été
élu il ya un an et demi la première fois
c'était donc en mai juin 58 et l'après
fac on a cité son nom à l'assemblée il
ya eu un tohu-bohu indescriptible
j'étais là on a dit fashi scandale et il
sait pas question de les pouvoirs à de
gaulle et notamment le groupe socialiste
étaient parmi les plus véhéments pour
protester contre l'évocation du nom de
de gaulle et puis quinze jours après
trois semaines après de gaulle est venu
on lui a voté des pouvoirs et le groupe
socialiste soit votée les pouvoirs
pourquoi c'est parce qu'il avait reconnu
la nécessité de la situation nouvelle
mitterrand n'a pas voté les pouvoirs de
nouveau et bien moi je vous dis comme au
mois de d'avril prochain
si les français ont voulu un changement
de politique si l'on telle une majorité
de députés l'udf et du rpr qui sont
prêts à appliquer cette politique vous
croyez que rangs des députés qui ne
voteront pas la confiance c'est ce
qu'ils disent donc eh bien vous verrez
ils vont ainsi les biens risque pourrait
se dire ne met quinze mille sont
terminées et pas les 25 minutes
nettement il est donc hors de question
surgit
donc je voulais vous demander puisque il
va me rester quelques questions
simplement sur les questions le sait le
16 mars au soir commence de fait la
campagne des présidentielles
de fait je veux dire c'est pas une de la
polémique de dire ça c'est la
cohabitation d'une certaine manière ça
va être le nom va prendre la campagne
des présidentielles alors la question
que je me posais je voulais vous poser
tel suivante est un peu que tout le
monde se pose cette question le monde se
dit est-ce que la vème république
endurant comme ça en produisant beaucoup
de premier ministre puisqu'elle produit
comme ça deux ou trois par serena et
tous sont des candidats crédibles sans
compter excusez mon indiquent-elles
délicatesse les anciens présidents les
libertés y aura peut-être un deuxième
alors est ce que tout ça ça ne fait pas
un trop plein de candidats qui risque
d'étouffer le fonctionnement la vème
république
comment les élimine
à ces candidats le poison des plus à la
mode
oui et les cendres est ce que ça suffit
ou non un sondage donne une indication
d'abord je crois que ça c'est naturel
que quelqu'un qui a été premier ministre
songe à être aux prairies naturelles
il a été numéro 2 il a vu comment danser
l'état et il s'est souvent déjoué en
cause
donc c'est naturel c'est naturel aussi
quelqu'un qui a été président se disent
peut être un jour si les circonstances
le rende utile chez les gens le choix
est bon donc ça fait beaucoup de monde
et notre système n'est pas bon alors
comment ni limite 1 comme nous n'avons
pas un système américain c'est à dire
des partis qui se réunit ce qui filtre
les candidats il faudrait que si sam
n'est pas bon
alors j'espère que la sagesse des
français corrigera les défauts du
système qui vont éliminer c'est eux qui
devront alors ma dernière question une
question alors là tout le monde se
posait de questions vous êtes un ancien
président a rappelé vous connaissez tout
du fonctionnement de cette constitution
vous avez été aux commandes et maîtriser
cet appareil qui à votre avis dans votre
âme et conscience serait le meilleur
président un public pour la france de
monsieur françois mitterrand de raymond
barre vous auriez à choisir vous sur les
i qui comme meilleur président pour la
france quoi pour l'avenir dans ce jeu
répond sans hésiter je voterai toujours
pour un candidat libéral est donc dans
le choix que vous proposez raymond barre
merci monsieur vidarte
merci nous retenons asvp gens lui le
sait d'une autre question de
téléspectateurs oui je vous disais tout
à l'heure monsieur le président que nous
avions ici beaucoup de questions sur
l'audiovisuel pourquoi les radios et les
télévisions libres n'ont elles pas pu
voir le jour sous votre présidence
que pensez-vous des deux nouvelles
chaînes ne risquez-vous pas de remettre
en cause le pluralisme et la démocratie
dans les médias 6au porter atteinte à la
haute autorité audiovisuelle en la
supprimant alors j'ai apporté mes
enfants ne pourraient pas lire
naturellement mon projet de proposition
de loi qui est sorti aujourd'hui
relative à la liberté de la
communication
oui parce que j'ai déjà présenté au jld
est présente et c'est ça mon talent
vient de sortir en janvier sortira
l'assemblée je crois en effet que la
liberté en france à ne pas être une
liberté concédée c'est-à-dire que l'on
distribue tous les jours
dans la même famille d'ailleurs les
conceptions de télévision en france
la liberté est beaucoup plus simple
quand quelqu'un veut créer une
entreprise en france il veut créer un
journal s'il veut créer maison d'édition
il est libre de le faire et il doit
respecter des règles et ce que je
propose c'est le système des grands pays
moderne c'est à dire la liberté on peut
créer une station de télévision comme on
peut créer une maison d'édition en
respectant des règles et ces règles
doivent être naturellement les mêmes
pour tous ces règles il faut les passer
sous la liberté d'établissement de
diffusion tous absolument glissement
avec des règles d'établissement aussi
avec des règles parce que il ya d'abord
un problème de fréquences vous savez que
notre espace est assez saturé et que
donc il faut qu'il y ait des fréquences
disponibles et il peut y avoir des
candidats pour les mêmes fréquences à ce
moment là il faut qu est un choix mais
nous prévoyons dans notre projet d'abord
que tout ça doit être public c'est les
candidats créer une station de
télévision quelque part doit l'annoncer
doivent décrire leur système pour ce
syndiqué qui le fera marcher quelles
sont les horaires comment ils conçoivent
leur faute et il faut qu'ils étaient un
certain délai pour tout le monde puisse
connaître le projet alors ensuite on
supprime la haute autorité de
l'audiovisuelle pourquoi ce n'est pas
qu'elle n'est pas sur certains points
fait des efforts il a fait des efforts
mais les nommés par le pouvoir politique
c'est mauvais quand on est nommé par le
pouvoir politique de toute façon nommé
par quelqu'un en ce sens plus ou moins
lié lui même d'ailleurs considère qu'on
a telle ou telle obligation vis-à-vis de
lui donc ça doit être des magies lui
mais dans quel délai vous êtes un média
mais dans quel délai au printemps 80
crise en 186 bonfa voter une loi sur la
liberté liberté de l'audiovisuel et on
crée une commission nationale de la
communication comme dans les grands pays
composé de magistrats et de magistrats
désignés par leur corps c'est-à-dire
dévié par la cour de cassation par le
conseil d'état et par la cour des
comptes et eux mêmes se réunissent
cooptent des personnalités qui pense que
c'est utile des personnes qui
connaissent si vous voulez là les médias
et ils élisent en leur sein leurs
présidents présents se soit totalement
indépendant du pouvoir politique et
c'est eux qui feront le travail actuel
du gouvernement
non pas de ministre de l'information
mise de l'information c'est la
caractéristique des pays qui sont
politiquement sous développés vous
supprimez ça et c'est une commission
judiciaire qui répartit simple droit
super mais il n'y a pas actuellement ma
connaissance de ministre de
l'information il ya il ya qu'est ce
qu'un départ la technique de la et
quelqu'un qui parle comme s'il était
ministre de former les équipes de
techniques la commune i wish aucune
notion de ce qu'est ce que vous faites
de monsieur berlusconi
qu'est ce que vous faites de la sixième
chaîne alors là aussi voyez les gens se
disent peut-être qu'après ces élections
n'y aura pas de changement
arrêté il ya un grand changement c'est
que l'attitude du gouvernement ne sera
plus du tout la même
le problème d'essieu berlusconi ça n'est
pas une affaire de gouvernement
c'est comme si on intervenait prenez les
cinq fils hier d'une conception mais je
vous réponds que c'est pour vous voyez
les différences
si vous prenez une autre activité
intellectuelle par exemple l'édition est
ce que vous imaginez qu'on va intervenir
parce que la table ronde de plombs parce
que les presses de la cité
la télévision fait de la pression
n'était pas nationalisées on ne vient
pas on ne vient pas de la même situation
on vient là même sur autre croix
vendredi les garde on parle des périodes
des problèmes contrat pour avis on vient
la situation alors vous me parlez de ce
qui existe et on est dans les raids sont
monotones il le concède à des gens à des
exploitants bon concrètement vous avez
un problème monsieur berlusconi qui va
commencer à émettre le 20 février
il aimait quand vous arrivez au pouvoir
vous fait quoi d'avoir causé pas besoin
d'y accéder c'est cocasse de voir que
les deux chaînes de télévision ont
commencé à fonctionner trois semaines
avant une élection alors on aura attendu
quatre ans et demi et elle commence pile
trois jours avant l'ouverture de la
campagne électorale
nous aurions fait ça ni l'une ni l'autre
ne fera de la formation donc je ne pense
pas que ces influences de façon
déterminante
le résultat les districts papa aurait un
terrain là on me rappelait en tout cas
ça permet de dire trois semaines avant
les élections qu'on a concédé des scènes
de télévision je crois simplement qu'il
faudra alors appliquer les règles de
droit commun je ne connais pas monsieur
berlusconi c'est pas mon problème
il faut que toutes les chaînes soient
dans la même situation
vous savez que nos recettes et la
publicité il faut qu'ils aient accès à
la publicité dans les mêmes conditions
il faut que leur devoir vis à vis du
cinéma biais de la création soient les
mêmes il faut que les règles qu'on leur
applique choix les mêmes par exemple sur
l'ordre alors appliqué rétroactivement
des règles de droit commun que vous
aurez préalablement modifié c'est ça
mais c'est là où c'est que c'est
toujours la règle en matière de
concessions
quand l'état fait des confessions et
qu'ils changent les règles générales
ça s'applique automatiquement aux
anciennes concessions d'accord c'est
très clair autre question jean louis la
scène oui monsieur le président
êtes-vous surpris par la remontée de la
gauche dans les sondages et comment
analysez-vous cette remontée il ya
quelques mois j'ai dit aux dirigeants de
de l'opposition ce qui à mon avis on
risquait d'arriver
parce que j'avais regardé ce qui s'était
passé en suède vous avez eue il ya six
mois des élections générales en suède à
peu près dans une situation comparable à
la nôtre et les socialistes suédois ont
mené leur campagne en utilisant deux
arguments la division de l'opposition
et là la peur que l'on revienne sur les
acquis sociaux
elles ont fait peur le pire il est digne
c'est vous parce qu'ils vont faire la
même chose ils ne peuvent plus proposé
l'espoir arrive on cherchait à faire
peur et depuis quelques semaines c'est
ce qui se passe on explique que le smic
que les acquis sociaux tout ça ça va
être remis en question dit pas comment
dupas parking enfin on cherche à
répandre la peur dans l'opinion publique
et comme malheureusement l'image de
l'union de l'opposition
à mon avis est insuffisante et bien les
socialistes jouent sur deux choses sur
les divisions de l'opposition et sur la
peur est naturellement ça leur permet
quelques gains fraîche au point qui a
duré parce que j'ai vu les sodas sera
donnée aujourd'hui par exemple à paris
sur paris et je crois que le total des
socialistes et des communistes sur paris
doit faire 34% des voix
le total alors c'est peut-être une
remontée enfin on n'est pas une majorité
d'ici le 16 mars sur paris situation un
peu particulière
d'autres questions svp oui monsieur le
président si vous arrivez au pouvoir
accepteriez-vous une coalition des
partis suivants udf
rpr et certains socialistes notre
téléspectateurs qualifie de raisonnable
mais j'ai insisté socialiste dit
raisonnable et est devenu libéraux ce
qui suppose qu'ils aient quitté leur
parti naturellement je veux dire la
majorité réunira tous les libéraux qui
seront d'accord sur le programme de
gouvernement et edf rpr mais ce qui est
tout à fait clair c'est que comme
formation politique il n'y aura que
l'udf et le rpr et que la ligne
politique floue que jean lesage 7 c'est
celle qui est décrit dans le document
dans le programme dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure avec alain duhamel ce
président pendant que vous parliez tout
à l'heure et serge july de la
cohabitation de se reposer une question
dont nous avons le résultat seulement
maintenant pour des raisons de circuits
d'ailleurs la question était monsieur
mitterrand de thil perdre de ses
pouvoirs en cas de victoire de
l'opposition
une question sur le sentiment que les
gens ont voici les réponses oui 42% non
46 % sans opinion
12 % sont à jour vos commentaires mais
qui ne seront pas que c'est une très
bonne question je m'excuse que tu as
peur de ses pouvoirs il garde ses
pouvoirs constitutionnels
il faut revenir toujours à ça donc ils
vous posiez la question
le chemisier rang doit-il conserver ses
pouvoirs constitutionnels
moi je dis oui nous allons la poser
comme ça ça va peser comme ça pour voir
si vous avez convaincu les français bon
maintenant albert du roy pour un quart
d'heure comme tout le monde albert des
eaux
c'est un quart d'heure où ces 25 minutes
c'est un ami un quart d'heure comme tout
le monde c'est bon ça y reste beaucoup
de travail
il reste beaucoup de questions abordées
donc ce ne sera pas de trop d'autant que
mon excellent confrère serge hugon nous
on a sauté une tout à l'heure parce
qu'ils vous interroger sur ce que vous
feriez une élection présidentielle dans
le cas d'un second tour entre mitterrand
et barrez vous avez dit bart
mais le premier tour entre chirac et
barre qu'est ce que vous faites vous
je suis venu parler ce qui intéresse les
français ont du sens de second tour je
réponds aux chaussures autour ce fut on
ne répondait pas sur les derniers bons à
beaucoup de monsieur chirac
l'autre jour il s'est fâché dans un
meeting je crois vulgaire soir garantir
soirée il a dit je ne veux plus entendre
parler de la cohabitation ordinateur
vous vous souhaitez en parlez pas du
tout gare au magazine
récemment vous avez annoncé mais non
seulement votre conférence de presse mme
velly que vous souhaitiez en parler à
cette heure de vérité nous mêmes a
ajouté je souhaiterais en parler
longuement
oui enfin bon je souhaiterais pauvre
question là je crois exactement ce que
j'ai dit c'est dit je crois que les
français ont du mal à comprendre ce qui
se passera après le 16 mars de renvoyer
tout à l'heure et je souhaite qu'il le
comprenne mieux parce que quand on doit
voter
on engage son pays que ça des
conséquences il faut savoir ce qui va se
passer
donc je souhaite répondre à des
questions sur ce qui va se passer mais
je trouve que chirac a raison il ne faut
pas parler de la cohabitation il faut
parler de la constituent je dis
simplement que la france comme tous les
grands pays
j'ai rencontré récemment à sa note de
cet état étranger personne n'a mis en
doute que les la france appliquerait de
sa constitution enfin qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire donc simplement
le jeu que les français sachent ce qu'il
y a dans la constitution
c'est maintenant et tout à l'heure aussi
vous avez commencé une réponse vous
venez de dire que vous pensiez que aucun
des députés qui se sont engagés sur la
plateforme rpr udf ne voterai contre la
confiance au gouvernement
et vous avez commencé une phrase vous
avez dit il peut y avoir l'une ou
l'autre personnalité qui vous pensiez
quelqu'un oui je pense bien sûr puisque
raymond barre l'a dit la carte et la
bombarde ce n'est pas un député élu
parmi d'autres c'est quelqu'un qui a une
personnalité propre qui peut avoir des
raisons personnelles de prendre une
telle attitude
mais je suis convaincu que les députés
puisque c'est ça la question la majorité
c'est les députés que les députés qui
auront été lu votre honte à votre avis
pourquoi est ce que raymond barre a pris
7 cette attitude à l'égard de la
cohabitation
je crois mais s'avoue lui avait posé la
question est il est venu ici ça je crois
qu'il a l'idée qu'il est impossible
d'agir en france utilement si on ne
rétablit pas la totalité des éléments
qui permettent de bien gouverner et
parmi ces éléments le fait que le
président la république est d'accord
avec la nouvelle majorité parlementaire
et moi j'ai une approche qui est
d'autres qui est de dire c'est en effet
la meilleure situation
la situation préféra mais c'est une
situation qu'on ne peut rétablir que
dans le cadre de la constitution et donc
pour la rétablir pour faire deux choses
il faut changer la majorité
parlementaire et gouvernementale
le 16 mars ce que j'espère les français
vont faire et puis ensuite il faudra à
l'essence normale en 1988 mettre
d'accord la majorité présidentielle et
la majorité parlementaire le sujet la
constituent et messieurs bardés quand on
interroge là-dessus fait référence aussi
à lui une lecture boulistes gaullienne
de la constitution donc sous-entendu
vous n'auriez pas cette même lecture
goal is to go again
j'ai été très longtemps ministre du
général de gaulle
l'occasion lui parler de tous ces sujets
en particulier n'a parlé je me souviens
très bien en 1965 au moment de sa
réélection est en 1967 au moment où la
majorité est très indécis devons parler
de ces sujets et je n'aime pas cette
expression lecture fou de faire cros
titution mais pas de lecture de la
constitution
qu'est ce que c'est que ça lire un texte
vous prenez ce texte vous voyez ce qu'il
y a deux dents c'est tout à fait clair
dernière question sur vos propos de la
position de raymond barre est ce que
vous excluez qu'il agisse comme mondiale
par calcul personnel non je crois qu'il
a cette conviction il a cette conviction
est ce que je pense par contre c'est que
si l'on cherchait
à mettre tout de suite d'accord les deux
majorité c'est-à-dire parlementaires et
présidentielles on entrerait dans une
cascade d'élections en france dont je ne
sais pas comment on sortirait parce que
vous savez que ça suppose une élection
présidentielle en côte printemps
prochain ensuite paraît-il un référendum
pour changer la loi électorale et
ensuite une nouvelle élection
parlementaire avec une autre loi
écoutez je vous laisse à penser le
l'état de la france si elle a quatre
élections générales en 1986 est ce un
peu comme le la rivière des tribunes
siens quand vous sautez trois obstacles
vous n'êtes pas sûr de sauter le
quatrième et si on a quatre élections
générales en gagner trois et en perdre
une
je pense qu'il vaut mieux moi c'est ce
que je souhaite c'est que la france
donne au monde l'exemple d'un pays
capables de traverser une période
difficile difficile en respectant les
règles que nous nous sommes donnés à
nous-mêmes se dire notre constitué et
par son attitude raymond barre rend
compliqué cet objectif ne l'auront pas
compliqué certainement le sens de
l'intérêt national il ne cherchera pas à
le rendre compliqué simplement il dit
qu'il se tiendra à l'état
alors parlons de deux de l'union
d'accord la coalition rpr et udf
le sondage que antenne 2 événements du
jeudi ont publiés montrent que les deux
électorats sont d'ailleurs très très
proche sur l'unité des problèmes ce sont
les mêmes alors pourquoi y at-il de
partir
c'est l'histoire politique de la france
cible et il ya un parti qui vient du
gaullisme et donc de ce qui s'est formée
à partir de 1958 et puis quelques
parfois même plus loin et l'autre c'est
l'héritage une grande tradition
politique sont des archaïsmes en voie de
disparition
ce sont en tout cas certainement des
courants qui doit se rapprocher
peut être même plus tard dans l'avenir
se rapprocher encore plus c'est à dire
finalement qu'à la fusion ou est pas
maintenant mais je ne pense que dans
l'avenir sous léon devrait arriver une
structure encore plus unitaire est ce
que si cette coalition et au lendemain
des élections initiative solide exerce
solidairement le pouvoir est ce que
votre avis l'aboutissement logique de ce
fonctionnement solidaire du pouvoir ne
doit pas aboutir deux ans
plus tard si les échanges sont respectés
à une candidature unique et la
présidence de la république
non je le pense pas appelé parce que on
en parlait tout à l'heure et n'avons pas
un bon système de sélection des
candidats alors si vous avez un candidat
unique c'est vrai que c'est les partis
qu'ils auront choisie sera donc un
candidat de parti c'est pas la peine
d'avoir une élection présidentielle je
crois qu'il faudra traiter l'élection
présidentielle à deux tours que le
premier tour comme une primaire il est
normal que les électeurs marque une
certaine préférence mais ce qui est tout
à fait sûr je suis sûr que ça se
produira d'ailleurs cette fois là c'est
qu'au deuxième tour il faut que tous
ceux qui partagent les mêmes idées et
c'est à dire l'udf et le rpr et les
tendances voisine soutiennent à fond le
candidat qui ont été placés en tête
puisque nous parlons de l'union je
voudrais vous dire qu il me paraît utile
que y est une manifestation qui montrent
à l'opinion publique que cette union
existe et vous rappeler qu'au mois de
juin au moment où commençait à préparer
déjà cette échéance j'avais organisé ce
qu'on appelle la convention libérale et
j'avais invité il était venu les grands
dirigeants de l'opposition
c'est d impression un peu ambigu j'étais
là vous aimez bien sûr qu'ils soient là
oui c'est celle là ils se sont exprimés
et bien je propose qu'on refasse qu'on
fasse la même chose et je leur avais
proposé vous le proposez maintenant je
viens je leur ai proposé et je vous
invite aux reins oui les grever leur
méfiance de l'opposition c'est-à-dire du
rpr et l'udf et en particulier jacques
chirac raymond barre et jean lecanuet de
venir à clermont ferrand tenir ensemble
une réunion pour montrer à l'opinion
publique la réalité de l'union de
l'opposition quelle que soit en effet
sur certains sujets les différences qui
peuvent exister et je crois que clermont
ferrand c'est très bien choisi parce que
c'est à mi distance entre la corrèze où
tu représentes jacques chirac et lyon où
se présentent très longs bas et comme
par hasard c'est chez vous et très loin
on est au milieu c'est très loin pour
monsieur de qu'annuelle et le créneau
est un peu plus loin et puis faudra
aussi qu'elle est jeune dirigeant de
l'opposition me faut montrer que cette
opposition des jeunes leaders très très
brillant d'ailleurs et j'espère qu'ils
répondront comme patrick sébastien oui à
l'ovaire et ça sera quand il faut
chercher la date avec eux on ne veut pas
il faut regarder toujours d'année
le refus de l'un d'entre eux impliquerez
quoi pour vous vous interpréterez feriez
comment non je crois que le l'opinion le
regretterai je rentre l'opinion et dans
la tente de manifestations unitaires
je reviens sur les différences c'est
vrai qu'il ya des différences mais il ya
un énorme tronc commun parce que d'abord
dans ce tronc commun il yal'idée
j'aurais voulu que l'on parle davantage
qu'il est nécessaire de changer la
politique économique de la france
tout le monde le pense par le temps
chirac le pense je le pense
et d'autre part il ya un autre élément
du tronc commun c'est qu'il faut gagner
les élections de mars prochain
la commençons par gagner les élections
de mars prochain pour cela manifestons
l'union et puis ensuite on mettra en
oeuvre
alors malgré malgré tous vos efforts il
reste un certain nombre de départements
ain qu'hier à peu près où il n'y a pas
de listes d'union udf rpr
un électeur d'un de ses départements
vous interrogez vous dis voilà j'ai le
choix
qu'est ce que vous me conseillez vous
lui répondez quoi je lui dit voter pour
l'udf ou pour leurs pairs donc les liens
qui vous ont uni jadis d'avec à l'udf
sont effacés vous n'avez pas une
préférence j'appartiens à l'udf mais je
considère que les électeurs de
l'opposition sont libres de choisir
entre l'udf et elles sont libres mais
vous demande un conseil de non pas parce
que vous ne donnez pas voté pour lui
n'est fait pour leur père et je le dis à
eux et je dis aux autres parce que s'ils
ne votent pas pour l'udf est pour le rpr
je le répète c'est quand même simple et
puis parlons un peu des affaires
sociales par des moyens arrivé bien
s'ils ne votent pas pour l'udf est pour
lui un père la france sera ingouvernable
et si la france est ingouvernable elle
sera malheureuse
la france ne se dire les français seront
malheureux encore des questions
politiques auxquels vous pouvez répondre
très brièvement avant d'arriver à
d'autres questions économiques ou
sociales est-ce que vous l'approuvez où
vous reconnaissez le droit au président
de la république d'être intervenu à la
campagne électorale comme il l'a fait je
crois qu'il ya deux choses
il est tout à fait naturel que le
président de la république exprime sa
préférence
françois mitterrand est socialiste
il est tout à fait naturel qu'il exprime
sa préférence pour le socialisme en
france
par contre je ne trouve pas une bonne
chose qu'il partait ici pour meeting
d'un parti
et je crois que c'est différent moi même
comme président je suis intervenu en
1978 publiquement avant et avant
l'élection peut vidéo avait fait pareil
et je crois que c'est naturel je ne
critique pas du tout on a une conviction
on exprime sa conviction c'est ce que
j'ai appelé la formule fait recette
le bon choix pour la france mais par
contre je n'ai jamais fait dans un
meeting politique est d'ailleurs ni
mystère fourni de gaulle ne sont jamais
allés dans des bété c'était quand même
un métier c'était un meeting était une
rassemblement ces deux rassemblements
est rentré rassemblements et meetings
ont cédé change de ville car un parti et
le palais les dirigeants du parti les
secrétaires de soucier de cela non cités
français qui étaient là vous avez le la
veille du scrutin de 78 vous êtes
intervenu e après la clôture de la
campagne officielle le soir dans le
journal le télévisée pour rappeler le
bon choix
il vous semblerait donc normal que le
suivi terran fasse la même chose cette
fois-ci le 15 mars de très bonnes
critiques la porte quelqu'un qui ferait
ce que j'ai fait fall pourquoi les
cheveux c'est utile de le rappeler
c'était d'abord pour dire qu'on est fait
je pensais moi pour la france c'était le
bon choix et ensuite pour rappeler que
le choix des français seraient
appliquées pour ça que j'ai fait et je
leur ai dit rappelez vous si vous votez
pour le programme commun vous aurez le
programme commun car moi président de la
république je n'ai pas les pouvoirs de
m'y opposer
h3 xi françois mitterrand intervient il
est naturel qu'ils disent qu'elle est sa
préférence mais il faut rappeler aux
français de français pour qu'ils le
sachent que la politique qui sera
appliqué c'est celle qu'ils choisiront
en face son intervention ne sera pas
scandaleuse le premier ministre
récemment sur votre place sur ce plateau
là
m'a dit que il parlait de la
modernisation de l'industrie des
problèmes que savait entraîner des
conséquences peuvent être entraînés et
il a dit nous avons fait le sale boulot
est-ce que disons pas le sale boulot
mais ce que les socialistes ont fait une
partie du sale boulot ce qu'ils
appliquaient vous ne l'aviez pas fait
avant votre gouvernement
c'est un peu une spécialité socialiste
ça et on va la retrouver sur d'autres
sujets je rappelle quand on a commencé à
moderniser la sidérurgie française
il ya longtemps c'était sous le
gouvernement de raymond barre je te
président de la république et on a
annoncé la restructuration de la
sidérurgie lorraine
il ya une énorme manifestation qui a eu
lieu contre la restructuration et y
avait au 1er rang de secrétaires premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste de
l'époque françois mitterrand qui
protestaient contre la modernisation et
si vous en doutez rechercher les images
de la télé vous levez renommer à coudre
ou appeler parfaite inconnue alors c'est
assez comique de venir dire maintenant
nous prouve nous empêchons la
modernisation quand on était dans
l'opposition il fallait que vous alliez
plus vite la modernisation as tu
commencé depuis longtemps dans certaines
entreprises elle a été sévère dans de
grands secteurs le secteur minier le
secteur de la sidérurgie
certains secteurs du textile etc elle
était commencée avant elle a été
poursuivie
est ce qu'elle est à l'heure actuelle
tout à fait terminée et on tombe sur le
problème de l'emploi par vous savez
avant france à l'heure actuelle 3
millions de chômeurs en réalité aurait
fait pas confiance aux statistiques
officielles ou non mais les cinq chiots
ciel disent la même chose seulement
simplement on est très discret parce que
on dit qu'il ya à peu près deux millions
quatre cent cinquante et un chômeur mais
on oublie de dire qu'il ya 190 milles
tuque et vous savez clés tu quand on les
recrute
il reste des demandeurs d'emploi et de
notre petit qui livre qu'on leur donne
ya marqué vous êtes encore demandeurs
d'emploi ils sont encore inscrits à
l'anpe puis vous avez 185 mille
personnes qui étaient demandeurs
d'emploi qu'on a rayé
alors là je trouve sur cet intéressant
d'ailleurs pour la formation de savoir
qui c'est parce que ça peut être des
gens qui ont été découragés ou qui
séduira aucune chance de trouver un
emploi c'est certainement pas des gens
qui ont retrouvé du travail
monzon les chiffres de l'ofs
parce que c'est simple j'ai regardé les
derniers chiffres fin décembre nous
avons en au vert cinquante-huit mille
700 demandeurs d'emploi à l'heure
actuelle et nous avons comme offres
d'emploi 685 offre d'un côté 57000 de
l'autre côté 685 offre c'est-à-dire une
offre pour 84 demandes mais si vous
prenez des classes de lycée à l'heure
actuelle et jason lee center à peu près
40 élèves rappelle que quand il en avait
30 à notre époque on disait que c'était
un scandale
actuellement ils ont à peu près 40 bien
ça veut dire que sur deux classes du
lycée qui sortiront au printemps
prochain à clermont ferrand
vous aurez une place offerte pour les
élèves des deux classes
moi la situation de l'emploi alors ça
c'est la réalité de la france
et comment va-t-on redresser cette
situation j'aimerais bien qu'on en parle
alors dans pour pour aborder cette
période difficile et faire cet effort
que l'écran qu'on demandait qu'on
demandera à tous les français il faut
évidemment l'idéal séclier une espèce de
consensus social et il ya une question
qui peut-être préoccupante dans la plate
forme de l'opposition et un certain
nombre de mesures que vous avez
explicité expliqué très clairement tout
à l'heure de la nécessité de diminuer un
certain nombre de de teint peau de
supprimer l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes et c'est bon il ya aussi
l'abandon de la loi de démocratisation
du secteur public des choses comme ça
est ce que cette plateforme ces exemples
le prix dans la plateforme ne manque pas
d'une contrepartie parce qu'on va
demander un effort va demander une très
grande flexibilité de l'emploi par
exemple qui dépasse largement celle de
la loi actuelle est ce que l'effort
qu'on va demander aux gens l'effort
d'adaptation à la con va demander aux
gens ne doit pas trouver une
contrepartie quelque part qu'est ce que
les gens demandent à l'heure actuelle et
demande que ça marche mieux
ce terrain c'est ça qui demande une
chose qu'il faut qu'il sache c'est que
si on ne change pas de politique ça ne
marchera pas mieux alors que vous avez
une intoxication formidable sport on
explique à partir de quelques indices
par exemple un deal des prix que tout va
bien en france
il est quand même fantastique et j'irai
à mon avis scandaleux
qu'on ne parle absolument pas de
l'emploi on ne parle absolument par
désendettement de la france c'est quand
même fantastique il est probable qu'on a
passé le 1er janvier le cap des mille
milliards d'endettement pour là vous ne
répondez pas avec l'état déloge ils
répondent c'est un thème intéressant
mais vous n'avez avec verifone
alors c'est fantastique et on fait
croire à l'heure actuelle que la
situation française est il facile
qu'elle s'améliore
moi je prends un exemple concret
l'industrie automobile j'ai lu dans un
journal allemand que pour la première
fois en 1985 convient d'avoir les
chiffres
la france n'est plus le deuxième
constructeur d'automobiles en europe
nous étions depuis des années le
deuxième constructeur on est devenu le
troisième dépassé par les anglais il ne
savait que nos talonné par les italiens
il est près semblable 186 on sera le
quatrième constructeur d'automobiles en
europe la situation de la france qui
s'enfonce alors vous nous dit on va
prendre des mesures sociales provocante
et sûrement pas non j'ai pas dit ah
enfin un peu comme un petit peu produit
tout on va prendre les mesures qui
permettront à l'économie française de
redémarrer mais c'est ça que les gens
attendent
à l'heure actuelle qu'est ce qu'on leur
dit on leur dit plus on s'éloigne du
socialisme mieux ça marche
et bien moi je dis puis on s'éloignera
du socialisme mieux ça marchera les
résultats actuels de la gestion c'est
pas parce qu'on fait beaucoup de
socialisme c'est parce qu'on en fait peu
tout le monde le sait les communes sur
les premiers d'ailleurs à le dire et
bien dans ce cas là il faut pas voter
pour des socialistes qui font peu de
socialistes il faut voter pour des gens
qui seront capables faire marcher
l'économie française et donc je le dis
plus on s'éloignera du socialisme mieux
ça marchera dernière question à la
dernière question alors je change de
thème qu'est ce que c'est la dernière
ma dernière le
robert hersant a n'a pas respecté une
loi votée au parlement
et d'ailleurs il le reconnaît on a
demandé aujourd'hui sa levée la levée de
son immunité parlementaire devant le
parlement européen
est-ce que cela vous semble normal
d'ailleurs toute cette affaire est vicié
à la base mais n'a pas respecté une loi
non j'ai eu bien la corse mort elle est
malheureusement vicié à la base j'avais
des situations dans la vie des pays où
malheureusement celui-ci à la base car
on a fait une loi sur la presse dont on
a dit que c'était une loi contraire san
quentin pays s'amuse à faire des lois
contre une personne
il crée une situation qui est impossible
donc on ne peut ne pas respecter une
mauvaise l'europe ne dis pas qu'on ne
peut on ne doit pas faire de loi contre
une personne qu'est ce que je vous dis
simplement c'est que j'espère que la maj
nouvelle majorité fera des lois
générales
d'ailleurs il ne faut pas faire de loi
sur la presse les gens qui ont fait des
lois sur la presse ont laissé un mauvais
souvenir dans l'histoire disons même
d'ailleurs déclenché des révolutions
certains journalistes rivaux les maths
il faut pas faire de loi sur la presse
faut faire une loi générale sur la
communication
cette loi générale sur la communication
s'appliquera à tout le monde mais comme
ça ce sera une loi juste qu'elle ne
visera pas telle ou telle personne tel
ou tel groupe
à ce moment là je suis persuadé que tout
le monde leur espèce qu'on a le droit de
ne pas respecter une mauvaise loi on le
doit pas respecté une mauvaise douane on
doit faire de mauvaises mans d'accord
donc le
les instances introduites à l'encontre
de monsieur versants sont normales le
gouvernement est dans sa logique
qu'ayant fait une mauvaise doigts et
cherche la faire appliquer bien nous
retournons à s est fait pour une
dernière question avant d'aller conclure
l'émission avec jérôme jaffré à la
sofres oui deux dernières questions avec
pour la première de formulation pour une
même question que pensez-vous de gars en
question sorte ça fait 2 formulations
pour la première question que
pensez-vous de l'emprunt giscard que
pensez-vous du ministre des finances qui
a émis un emprunt qui va coûter 30 fois
plus que son intérêt fut question qu'on
pose l'amour à une question vous eh bien
vous devriez vous réjouir que pour une
fois les épargnants français n'ait pas
été volé d'abord je vous rappelle que
l'endettement de la france on se moque
de vous l'endettement intérieur de la
france mon empreinte 1 entre intérieur
il sera passé entre 81 et 86 2 400
milliards à 1000 milliards
donc les gens qui ont fait 600 milliards
d'emprunts au cours des quatre dernières
années n'ont pas de leçons à donner en
matière d'emprunt et d'autres parlons
pas nous avions fait qu'est-ce que
c'était c'était un emprunt qui avait une
garantie sur l'or qui était ouvert à
tout le monde
c'était pas pour les privilégiés et
c'est tout le monde pouvait souscrire à
ce moment-là l'achat d'or était libre
aucun français pouvaient s'ils voulaient
acheter de l'or à la place et ce qui
s'est passé c'est simplement que
l'emprunt a suivi l'évolution du cours
de l'or il est monté mais pas on n'est
pas vraiment prévu non c'est dire qu'à
ce moment là on ne prévoyait pas c'est
vrai la crise monétaire de des années
soixante et onze mais il a suivi le
cours de l'or est par exemple récemment
il a commencé par monter puis la bessée
et ça veut simplement dire que l'état
français n'a pas volé les épargnants et
que l'état français n'a pas été volé lui
même puisque comme nous avions acheté
lors nécessaire pour garantir l'emprunt
l'état à tout ce qui lui faut pour
rembourser cet emprunt le dernière
question oui selon monsieur le président
quel est le profil d'un jeune giscardien
aujourd'hui c'est une très bonne
question ça va le profit la jaunisse
cardiaque d'abord c'est quelqu'un de
jeune et ils vont se réunir et je leur
ai suggéré de ne réunir que des jeunes
entre 18 et 21 ans
c'est à dire des gens qui n'ont jamais
voté et permettez moi de vous le dire
des gens qui ne voteraient pas si
j'avais pas fait baisser l'âge électoral
l'on se réunir et ils vont voir ce qui
les intéresse dans la politique
française
je crains que ce qui les intéresse c'est
pas tellement ce que nous avons dit ce
soir je le dis franchement j'aurais
préféré moi j'étais venu pour parler de
choses très concrètes plus concrète que
je vis sur le terrain que je vais leur
vie d'ailleurs à partir de la semaine
prochaine
je crois que c'est quelqu'un de libéral
que c'est quelqu'un qui a envie de créer
c'est quelqu'un qui ne se sent plus
d'inégalités qui ne veut plus
d'inégalités culturel et social et c'est
quelqu'un qui voit la france dans le
monde
c'est à dire qui c'est que nous sommes à
la fois citoyen notre pays mais pour
beaucoup de sujets pour beaucoup de
grandes causes également citoyen du
monde
vous aviez quelques doutes sur la façon
dont dans votre discours de ce soir
était accueillie par les français
nous allons tout de suite elle est la
sofres nous attend gm jaffré directeur
des études politiques de sofres qui va
tirer des conclusions sur la façon dont
cette émission de ce soir était reçu par
le public
tu rigoles et malgré quelques incidents
techniques qui ont rendu plus difficile
notre travail nous avons essayer
d'apprécier l'impact de l'émission comme
c'est maintenant la tradition en posant
des questions juste avant l'émission
et puis en les posant à la fin de
l'émission pour voir un petit peu si
monsieur giscard d'estaing avait réussi
à faire bouger les france alors nous
avons choisi comme thème principal
d'études la cohabitation que pensent les
français de la cohabitation souhaite
t-il si la cohabitation existe qu'elle
dure jusqu'en 1988 le croit-il
alors première question si le rpr et
l'udf gagne les élections
en 86 et si monsieur mitterrand reste à
l'elysée est ce qu'on souhaite que la
cohabitation dure jusqu'en 1988
c'est très intéressant on voit là un
recul de l'idée de la cohabitation cours
de l'émission 45% des français juste
avant l'émission répondait oui ils ne
sont plus que 41 % après avoir entendu
monsieur giscard d'estaing pendant trois
quarts d'heure ils ont davantage entendu
le leader de l'opposition que
le futur leader de la majorité politique
parmi les autres personnalités après
mars 1986 donc un recul de l'idée de
cohabitation et ce qui est intéressant
c'est l'autre question croyez-vous que
la cohabitation puisse durer jusqu'en
1988 si le rpr et l'udf gagne dès avant
l'émission s'était très nettement non
28% répondait oui 56% répondait non à la
fin de l'émission c'est un nom encore
plus massive 24% oui 61% non et là je
dirais que les français sont logique
dans la mesure où il souhaite que
monsieur mitterrand garde de ses
pouvoirs actuels car dans la question
que nous avons posée tout à l'heure nous
avons précisé qu'il s'agit des pouvoirs
actuels exercées par monsieur mitterrand
et on avait une légère majorité pour
souhaiter que monsieur mitterrand
concert de ses pouvoirs
dès lors qu'il y aurait une jarre veille
jérôme on souhaite comme jérôme jaffré
veux m'attarder oui il serait peut-être
intéressant de poser la même question à
monsieur giscard d'estaing est ce que
vous croyez monsieur le président que la
cohabitation ira à son terme légal 1988
non je vais commenter un petit peu tout
ça c'est intéressant cette évolution ça
monte que en m'écoutant tout à l'heure
les téléspectateurs ont été pour le mans
convaincu qu'il fallait soutenir
l'opposition que finalement la politique
socialiste actuel tel qu'on leur
présente et au fond plus néfastes
c'est ça la remontée et donc les
arguments que j'ai donné pour qu'ils
votent et qu'il soutienne le changement
de politique en france ont eu un impact
positif alors au fur à mesure
naturellement des chouettes que les
dirigeants socialistes s'éloigne du
pouvoir mais je crois que tout dépend de
la manière dont vous leur posez la
question si vous l'avez poser la
question peut-on contraindre par la
force du président de la république a
quitté ses fonctions il aurait répondu
non et votre réponse à vous sur les
chances de que la cohabitation dure deux
ans j'évolue genève à lui pas ses
chances j'estime je souhaite pour la
france qu'il respecte sa constitution
jérôme jaffré série de questions est ce
que monsieur giscard d'estaing a été
jugé convaincant
là nous avons posé ces questions tout au
long de l'émission sur les thèmes
économiques et sociaux
sur la cohabitation précisément et enfin
sur les idées libérales défendu par
monsieur giscard d'estaing alors trois
fois la réponse est positive
c'est donc une certaine réussite pour
monsieur giscard d'estaing ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça l'est avec des
écarts assez réduit ce qui indique dieu
que nous sommes en campagne électorale
et qu' il est désormais moins facile de
faire bouger des français les deux camps
sont face à face et le sont de façon
assez serré semble-t-il à travers ces
questions enfin dernière chose la bonne
opinion à l'égard de monsieur giscard
d'estaing là aussi nous l'avons posée
juste avant le début de l'émission et
nous l'avons posée à la fin alors la
remarque qui apparaît c'est que d'abord
monsieur giscard d'estaing jouit
toujours d'une bonne image personnelle
50% de bonnes opinions 36 % de mauvaises
avant l'émission
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
retrouve très exactement le même
résultat à la fin de l'émission
alors que d'habitude nous avons une
progression des bonnes opinions et là on
retrouve le problème je dirais de
monsieur giscard d'estaing qu'on voit
dans tous les sondages depuis quatre ans
il jouit toujours d'une bonne image mais
il a du mal à réussir a progressé à
retrouver la confiance des français
et l'émission de ce soir semble et il
n'a pas fait bouger l'opinion
alors il sera intéressant de voir dans
les prochains mois comment les choses
évoluent monsieur le président un
commentaire en guise de conclusion
oui un commentaire sauf que après tout
le fait qu'ils ne voient pas logique pas
très bien 51 de bonnes impressions et 37
% de mauvaises je souhaite que ça ne
bouge pas du coup c'est le support du
jeu au flipper c'était pas mon intention
je peux essayer de faire de réponse est
de secouer la machine faisant des
réponses démagogiques ce n'était pas mon
ambition je voulais essayer de faire
avancer un peu la réflexion ou comme
cette émission je suis content de voir
qu'au total les téléspectateurs l'ont
jugée positive une conclusion maintenant
si vous le permettez je voudrais vous
donner le tiercé gagnant pas le matin
quand on quand on se lève quand on
écoute la radio que c'est ce que je fais
on donne le tiercé l'air tout à l'heure
au début de ces émissions on a donné le
tiercé pour demain et moi je voudrais
vous donner le tiercé le gagnant ce
tiercé c'est l'union de l'opposition le
respect de la constitution et l'économie
libérale
et je vous donne le tiercé dans l'ordre
il faut d'abord l'union de l'opposition
pour gagner car si l'opposition n'est
pas unie elle ne gagnera pas où elle
gagnera mal il faut ensuite le respect
de la constitution
parce que si la france à l'extérieur
donnent l'image que ne respecte pas sa
propre constitution son image se
dégradera dans le monde
et si au contraire nous respectons notre
constitution à nous notre image
s'améliorera dans le monde et puis le
troisième élément du tiercé c'est
l'économie libérale parce que nous ne
sortirons pas des difficultés actuelles
on ne créera pas d'emplois en france à
la mesure des besoins
s'il n'y a pas un changement de
politique économique et si nous ne
choisissons pas réellement l'économie
libérale voilà le tiercé gagnant pour la
france et je souhaiterais que vous
jouiez le tiercé gagnant pour la france
voilà et bien c'était l'heure de vérité
de valéry giscard d'estaing
prochain invité lionel jospin le 19
février a en effet à la demande de la
haute autorité antenne 2 a accepté de
décaler l'heure de vérité de jacques
chirac pour tenir compte de certaines
modifications de programme décidé par
les autres chaînes et assurer malgré ces
changements
l' équilibre de votre formation
politique eh bien nous recevrons jacques
chirac le 26 février après lionel jospin
et non pas le 5 février comme il avait
été convenu avec lui voilà bonsoir
[Musique]